what's up you guys movie retrospective
time once again and we've been talking
about doing this for a while but we
wanted to go back and do some of the
classic Universal monster movies yeah
because we really hadn't done a lot of
those like I know we've done them all
yeah I know we've done some like we did
some from the 40s like cat people and
stuff like that but I was like we really
haven't done any of the universal
monster movies so I started like putting
some of them in the patreon poll like I
think in the last poll I put this one
the mummy and I also put White Zombie
and uh this one won so it does seem like
at least the patrons uh do want us to
cover kind of these old classic movies
which is totally fine with me because I
really like them all so uh yeah so for
whatever reason just randomly because I
picked it it was on 2B uh we're talking
about the 1932 movie The Mummy I've
never seen it I saw it but a long time
ago I'd seen it a couple of times
because you know I love Boris Karloff so
I'm gonna watch anything that he's in
and I thought this was kind of cool
because I mean we did a show about Boris
Karloff and Bella Lugosi but this was
kind of like in he'd been in
Frankenstein obviously and he was kind
of like a big enough star that when this
movie was released like the poster just
had Karloff The Uncanny on it like it
didn't even have his whole name so he
was already like getting to be this big
star and I thought was cool about this
one is that he really um I mean he gets
to be like a character he's not I mean
he was great as Frankenstein's monster
obviously but he didn't really have any
lines or anything like that whereas this
one he actually kind of gets to be a
character I'm watching the movie I'm I'm
digging it and I'm going this is kind of
familiar and I was like oh this is
Dracula pretty much the retelling of
drag it is kind of like the same but
it's good though because there's a lot
more details is it just kind of
change the motif to Egyptian Ancient
Ancient Egypt uh uh dude comes out of
the Grave uh looking for his lost love
trying to find his woman and he's gonna
turn you know bring her back to life
well bring his dead girlfriend back to
life through a woman who's reincarnated
her soul it's kind of complicated
[Laughter]
and uh
karloff's has got to go toe-to-toe with
legosi's portrayal of [ __ ] Dracula
and uh that's a [ __ ] tall order okay
and how he does it is uh there's a lot
more character he's on screen a lot more
there's a lot more to his backstory he's
not really evil he's kind of sympathetic
he's a sorcerer he's not evil incarnate
you know what I mean but he's he has to
do some bad [ __ ] to get the mission done
um he's intelligent he's Suave like like
Dracula he's got his own Motif it's a
middle eastern motif
does he beat Dracula
no no but but the mummy the character it
did live throughout the ages this is a
classic movie and when you say the mummy
this is what they're talking about yeah
he doesn't beat Dracula but close
it's good what's interesting about this
maybe
um I kind of feel like it's Unique among
the universal monster horror Canon
because one it was actually one of the
very first horror movies ever to
actually be based on like an original
screenplayer like an original story
because obviously Dracula Frankenstein
[ __ ] like that that was always like
based on existing like an existing novel
or like you know Edgar Allan Poe stories
or something like that like they were
always basing it on something
um this one was actually kind of like
written to be an original screenplay and
they kind of wanted to I don't want to
say cash in because that sounds kind of
you know but uh they were kind of like
trading on you know the opening of King
Tut's tomb like back in the 1920s which
was like a huge deal because it was like
a huge Egyptian thing and so they wanted
to kind of like cash in on that but I
think like out of all the universal
monster movies this is the least like a
monster monster movie yeah I thought it
was going to be a dude in a mummy car I
think a lot of people that's not what
it's about it's not like that well now
the sequels which actually I shouldn't
even call them sequels because they're
not really anything to do with the
original movie this movie even though it
did have quote unquote sequels like the
mummy's hand and curse of the mummy and
all that other kind of stuff like later
on they didn't really have anything to
do with this story or this particular
mummy
um this was actually kind of like a
standalone so I think when you think
about like the shambling mummy with all
the bandages and stuff that's from one
of the later mummy movies and not this
one because really Boris Karloff is only
in like full mummy makeup for like a
minute or two and then the rest of the
time he's in his ardith Bay
um kind of guys yeah but it's cool yeah
which is really cool um they do some
good shots of him where he's using
mental powers on people he's an ancient
Egyptian sorcerer all right M hotep was
his name that was a real Egyptian guy he
was like an architect I think there were
several mhotep so I think it was yeah I
think it was like there's like a names
like but there wasn't but there was like
a famous Steve the ancient Egyptian yeah
but there was like a famous guy the
famous guy that was named him I think
Karloff did a good job of giving a a
kind of a likable bad guy who's kind of
suave and uh sophisticated
West the West Was Always uh kind of
intrigued with ancient Egypt and they
kind of bring that Motif with you
instead of you know instead of [ __ ]
volacia or Transylvania you're dealing
with Egypt all right land of mystery and
he's a man of mystery you know he does a
good job you know
I didn't realize you know he was part
Indian you know I didn't realize that
Karloff was was half Indian I always
thought he was just white you know uh
but no he does a good job as a middle
eastern guy too so this is the Middle
Eastern Dracula basically yeah it's good
though it's real good and uh
he's got powers of a sorcerers got uh
you know meditation pools that he can
look into and it's like he's crying yeah
dude yeah and he's rebuilt a damn uh
ancient Egyptian Shrine whereas where he
lives and uh he's got thralls which are
dudes that he's kind of has kind of like
renfield's you know uh and they're
[ __ ]
um Egyptian guys who you know they call
him the Newbie and the Nubian big old
newbie and Egyptian bodyguard who he
sends out to go [ __ ] do [ __ ] and
everything and um
and it's kind of he's kind of like
bringing back Old Egypt it's it's good
it's a good flick
um there's more there than than Count
Dracula he's got a lot more speaking
lines
uh the story is a little more
complicated
um
he's not a monster in the same way that
say a vampire is a monster
but and that's kind of that's kind of in
the favor of this character but I see
why
Dracula is far more popular and and
vampires are a lot more popular there's
a a different motif of physical Motif
that you can say yeah that's what this
Dracula there's a goth looking stuff
this doesn't quite have that this is
more kind of
you know the Sands of Egypt and time and
a long time ago that that's just
that's the motif you're gonna go with
with this you know what I mean which for
some reason I guess you know
westerners are going to probably favor
more of that black Gothic kind of look
of Dracula you know with [ __ ] capes
and [ __ ] it's more closer to their
culture but it's just it's still a great
movie and the movie was remembered you
know it's just not remembered as well as
as Count Dracula belugosi's portrayal
yeah I mean it did it did well with the
boxes like it was a pretty it was pretty
successful like enough that they'd made
other mummy movies even though they're
not direct sequels but it didn't do
quite as well as Dracula and
Frankenstein but I do kind of feel like
like I said I kind of feel like when
people remember like the mummy movies
from the universal monsters era they're
remembering like the later movies
because this one really and I'm gonna
say like Jack pierce the same guy that
did the Frankenstein's monster makeup on
Boris Karloff did the makeup for this
both the mummy and the artist Bay
versions and this might be a
controversial statement but I like this
makeup better than the Frankenstein's
monster it's as much as like the
Frankenstein's monster is like iconic
and amazing but there's something about
this makeup that just really looks and
even if like you watch it now and this
movie is like so old it's like from 1932
and this makeup looks incredible yeah
the mummy makeup looks incredible yeah
and then once he became demomified there
was still some mummification going on in
his face yeah he looked like he was like
made of like old paper like he looked
like he was he like he looked really old
and he looked like really creepy yeah
but they didn't really make him look
scary which I liked that they're trying
to reinforce the idea that he's kind of
a romantic character a tragic romantic
character yeah he is very tragic he does
bad [ __ ] but yeah he's trying to get his
wife back you know and that's why he got
sentenced to be killed the way he was
killed anyway see they didn't really
Mama they didn't really they didn't
really embalm him the way they did they
mummified him alive which yeah and then
which they do show and then it's like
it's pretty hard yeah and he was brought
back through through a a spell that
accidentally got reapplied on the river
The Scroll of Thoth Yeah Yeah by that
there's a lot of cool [ __ ] in this the
writing okay the story in the writing I
think is better than the Frankenstein
the movie Frankenstein and the movie
Dracula there's more to this it's a more
of a sophisticated story
technically it's a better movie
uh stylistically I think it's very
unique
um
it just didn't have a staying power of
[ __ ] yeah well I guess Dracula and
Frankenstein maybe because it was like
lesser less a straight up horror movie
and more I mean it does have horror
elements obviously because it's about
like a scary mummy but it has kind of
like more of a dark romance yes is it a
paranormal romance or a paranormal kind
of thing and I think you know what I
could be totally wrong about this but
you know how like the later iterations
of Dracula which maybe I think again
correct me if I'm wrong I think started
in the 70s like maybe with the Jack
Palance version like when they started
doing versions of Dracula where Mina was
like a Reincarnation of like his ex-wife
and then Francis Ford Coppola did it in
his movie because that wasn't in the
book no like none of that stuff
um I think that maybe they're drawing
that idea from this because this was
kind of like the the birth of that idea
where it's just kind of like I'm not
saying that the script that the
screenplay for this was the first time
that had ever been done it might have
been done before but I think that was
the first time you saw it like in a big
like a mainstream horror type movie that
you know he's trying to like resurrect
his law love kind of thing and then I
think that was picked up for
interestingly Dracula adaptations later
on like that was kind of Incorporated in
that because like I said this screenplay
was not based on anything I think like
the original concept which you know this
will make sense if you've seen the movie
The Original concept was based on a real
guy who was like an 18th century I think
like an alchemist or something and his
name was um Alessandro cagliostro and so
the original screenplay was supposed to
be kind of like about him but he was
going to be like this Wizard or an
alchemist or something like that who had
lived for 3 000 years
um because of like through magic or
because of like some chemical or
alchemical kind of press procedure that
he had done but then they wanted to
cross breed that with the whole curse of
the Pharaoh you know tootin Commons tomb
type of thing which was kind of all the
lyrics like I said because it was very I
mean it had been 10 years prior
but they wanted to incorporate that
whole ancient Egyptian theme as well so
they just cross-bred those kind of
things because the mummy in this one I
mean when Boris Karloff comes out as
like artist Bay he's very clearly a
wizard I mean he can do he like I said
he's got a scrying thing like in his
house like he can see what everybody's
doing he can cause heart attacks yeah
like at a distance like he's just doing
[ __ ] like that and like squeezing
people's and they have a heart attack in
their house he can access best at
through cats right as servants
um another real cool thing is that uh
turns out that the Egyptian gods were
real because they make an appearance the
Egyptian gods I thought that was real
cool they make well their power makes an
appearance through statues cool [ __ ]
sexy Isis statues in the movie all thick
and everything
is that bastet who is that then they
showed it it was a statue of Isis but uh
no it turns out the Egyptian gods were
real
um it was it was ahead of its time the
movie
um it's got its 30s
it's done in the 30s format it's got you
know that's the way they did things in
the 30s where they shot things and the
way dialogue was delivered and the
acting and everything is all very
thirties but there's something kind of
charming about that everything is cut
and dried black and white kinda
you know you know what kind of character
it is you're dealing with there isn't
any damn deception in it it's all kind
it just no real surprises too very rare
um well actually when it turns out the
Egyptian gods were real that was kind of
surprised I guess yeah I wasn't
expecting that yeah so
um
I recommend it's a good movie it's a
good movie I do as well now I watch it
right along with Dracula and
Frankenstein and I see why and the
Creature from the Black Lagoon it's you
know we gotta do that at some point too
because I really like that I haven't
seen the his Fu Manchu movie yeah
that's what that's called I looked it up
supposed to be really good he plays
basically just damn evil Chinese
Alchemist warlord type dude which I want
to see those
um
I think he only made one of them didn't
he
um
oh that's all that I remember but I
could be wrong about that but he only
made one food Mansion movie like I said
they've made a million Fu manchums I
also recommend really to this day the
best one of these old ones if you had
that has Karloff in it is still for me
gonna be black cat where he plays uh
Shalimar perilzig a [ __ ] evil
military officer who sacrificed his own
men on a Battlefield
and uh so he could consecrate evil
ground to build his satanic Palace and
that's kind of and that that I still
think is his best character it is uh the
black cat Boris Karloff belugosi man see
that one too if you haven't seen it
really good
what about all the bad [ __ ] happens into
it necrophilia stealing people's wives
[ __ ] Satanism Human Sacrifice torture
everything that it wasn't supposed to be
in an old movie was in it
yeah good movie well I mean this one's
pre-code too and there's nothing like
really controversial in this one
although I did laugh out loud at because
there's one scene
there's one scene that's between because
you know like I said there's a whole
reincarnation angle so there's like
actually a modern woman whose name is
Helen and she's half Egyptian and it
turns out that she's The Reincarnation
of you know the mummy or artist Bayes
you know a girlfriend who died like 3
700 years ago whose name is um
that is what her name is but yeah so
she's like the reincarnation
and so she starts to get like after
artif bay like does the you know Scroll
of thaw thing like trying to wake her
mommy Up Artist Bay is stuck in the
mummy's code name that's his new modern
name because he's portraying himself
he's he's undercover as a modern man
okay so if she says that word if you
haven't seen the movie that's what she's
talking about Heart Of The Bay is the
mommy yeah and ten years after he was
revived from the grave he's adopted a
new identity yeah because obviously he
can't walk around like that's not his
name
hotep you know what I mean that's not
who he is so he calls himself Bay yeah
artist bad artist big not Michael Bay
yeah that's a completely different game
but um but yeah so so he does this
trying to wake his girlfriend The Mummy
up and it actually awakens her you know
reincarnated Soul or whatever and so
she's like trying to get into the uh
Museum and she doesn't really like know
why and all this other kind of stuff so
she gets rescued by this dude and like
who they kind of become like boyfriend
girlfriend like immediately but there's
like one great line where he says
something about
um you know opening a tomb and like he
opening the you know wrappings off the
mummy like a female mummy that he had
found and he's like oh I almost kind of
like fell in love with her a little bit
and she says to him like Helen says to
him it's like dude something like oh do
you often like have to open tombs to
like find girls to fall in love with or
something do you always open Graves to
find girls to fall in love with right
the sound bite from White Zombie song
right because it's like yeah
the fact that she said that to him I was
like whoa I was like she just accused
him of necrophilia and he was just like
totally fine with he's like oh
I'm funny and I was just like well it's
kind of [ __ ] up all right but
uh himself on her he does I mean I love
you so you're coming with me right I
have decided I mean I guess it's like
lucky that she's into it but I don't
know she seemed a little she didn't
really seem to have a lot of choice in
them did that [ __ ] in the 30s and 40s a
lot of the 30s it's like well if a guy
likes you then you gotta get married
then you have to yeah he chose you she
doesn't really have anything in the
matter it's just kind of like it's like
well although nobody asks nobody asks
her facial expressions though were like
dude you're a [ __ ] trip
delusional yeah well the thing about it
that actress actually that plays Helen
in this I have her name like written
down Zita Johann I think is her name she
was primarily a stage actress
and uh she's gorgeous actually and she's
gorgeous in this uh movie like she's got
a great face looks like Betty Boop she
does a bit uh but yeah she was kind of
like a theatrical actress and apparently
she had such a horrible time on this set
amazingly because she really did not get
along with the director whose name was
Carl freund actually Carl freund I think
this was his first American film that he
directed although he had been the
cinematographer on Dracula and he was
also the cinematographer on Metropolis I
think
um and I think he helped in the
directing like of Dracula as well but
like this was his first movie that he
directed but apparently
um yeah him and Zeta Johan did not get
along at all and he um apparently was
like
like spread all kind of rumors about her
and like I mean I don't know if she was
like super [ __ ] and hard to work with
either but um he did like say a bunch of
bad [ __ ] but like he seemed to like do
[ __ ] to like spite her you know what I
mean
um like cut I don't know like cutting
some of her scenes and like making her
do [ __ ] in the movie and like more than
other people uh so much so that I think
she like passed out at some point and
actually she was so soured on the whole
experience that she was only in like a
handful more movies and she's like [ __ ]
this I'm going back to the theater it's
like a lot nicer so there's that too at
the end of the movie they got her in a
scant and a scanty [ __ ] um Egyptian
Priestess outfit too so they're trying
to give you some eye candy at the end
yeah I think a nice figure I think that
was one of the things that Carl freund
was like trying he's like I'm Gonna Make
You Do the whole movie topless and she
was like man screw you buddy she runs
around in basically long real
um thin
silk dresses I guess it looks like Silk
or satin yeah uh no bra
just you know but they did that back
then you know 30s 30s well she's like it
you know and she didn't show nudity so
they tried to skirt the and she's pretty
thin too so it's not like she had like
big old businesses
but but it looked pretty it was [ __ ]
kind of transparent you know you can see
and can we see we could see her build
you know can we talk about too like like
I said the mummy makeup in this because
there's two makeups but the hardcore
mummy like with all the bandages and
everything like that looks amazing and
the thing about it is that even though
Jack Pierce did Boris karloff's like
entire body like that like with all the
bandages and they said it took like
eight hours like to put on and like
another two hours to take off so they
were basically just like going 24 7 like
they they hardly didn't even sleep and
what they would have to do is they'd
have to put they said it was like layers
they would put layers on they'd blow dry
it like they had like there were some
stills of Boris Karloff like sitting
under the big like industrial hair dryer
or whatever they blow dry it and then
they put more on and then they would
blow dry it again so it was just like
and they said that when he was in that
mummy makeup like he couldn't talk like
his mouth was completely closed like he
couldn't you know he was just like a
crackling like it was like a candy shell
on the outside and he could walk and the
weird thing is that they did all the
bandage is but they never showed him in
the movie Walking in the whole thing but
the only scene where they show because
there's the scene where where the
dumbass
um you know trainee archaeologist at the
beginning like wakes him up by saying oh
I'm gonna open this box I'm not supposed
to open that has a curse on it and like
start reading this Scroll of Thoth uh
even though it says not to and then it
wakes The Mummy up but then all they
show is like the mummy's hand which also
looks amazing like the hand looks really
good like coming in and being like Jupe
and like taking the thing but there's a
still from that that actually shows uh
Boris Karloff in the whole thing like
standing there I don't know why they
didn't show in the movie although I kind
of think I kind of like that though
because then they just kind of show like
The Mummy leaves and then there's just
like a trailing bandages
a bunch of merchandise after the movie
of of Karloff in that outfit standing up
I mean they made models and they had if
I think posters and photographs
promotional shots of it but you don't
really see it in the movie but yeah just
from like here yeah but before we forget
though I gotta say that Karloff
[ __ ] crushes it in this movie he's so
great [ __ ] crushes it God that's just
that voice yeah it's like he looks like
he's so like intimidating and like
creepy but also kind of sexy at the same
time yeah yeah yeah it's he he he's he's
using all of his powers
to try to respond to the ghosties
[ __ ] Dracula and he holds his own I
mean I'm there for it I don't say it's
impossible to be
to beat [ __ ] lugosi's Dracula but he
matched it
you know
and it was it's remembered to this day
this movie because see it you know what
I mean
if when you see it you just you see
Karloff [ __ ] apply his [ __ ] trade
he crushes it crushes it in every
[ __ ] scene
and uh
it's as good as Dracula yeah well
because like I said he's almost like
you kind of even though he does bad [ __ ]
like he gives a lot of Blake people
heart attacks because it would base he's
just trying to wake up his girlfriend
right um you know and he's gonna have to
like you know spoiler alert he's gonna
have to like kill Helen to do it because
he wants her to be reincarnated in her
own body so they can like be living
mummies or whatever together it's like I
said it's very complicated
um so he wants to do bad things but he
kind of like 3 700 years ago he kind of
got [ __ ] over too because like his
girlfriend got killed and then he was
trying to like resurrect her like wake
her back up and everybody thought that
that was you know exactly and so then
they punished him by you know mummifying
him alive yeah and like scraping off
like all the names and like all the good
spells like from the inside yeah they
did they did their sarcophagus did their
homework when a dude was buried in
disgrace didn't matter what his rank was
They removed all the [ __ ] rank from
him his little [ __ ] beard things off
of the damn sarcophagus and and all the
protection spells and every all symbols
of Reich were taking it's like what they
did to [ __ ] anken yeah you know they
totally took every
symbol of his rank was taken he was and
he was a pharaoh because that's supposed
to [ __ ] you over in the next lady as
well because that's like the Supreme
punishment and they did like they did do
that and so they did the homework and
and the portrayal of ancient Egypt was
pretty good in this uh the costumes and
everything uh there was some funny [ __ ]
with the Arabs that they were working in
there you know what I mean I swear to
God they were talking some the white
guys were [ __ ] yelling out in a
[ __ ] fake Arabic I was like yeah I
don't like I'm not
I swear to God the dude the white dude
yelled out double up on the hashish
double
[Laughter]
he's like that's the only Arabic word I
know
and the average audience member wouldn't
have known what hashish was and he said
it in a certain way it was hard to
understand what he said double up on the
hashish
[Laughter]
side joke you know
like you're not gonna lie yeah
and put that in there just like as a
little Easter egg is there everybody
watching it being I see what she did it
was either double back on the hashish or
double up on the hashish something like
that it did definitely sound like
something yeah yeah because we were kind
of like laughing about
um you know because I you know I don't
know like I said I don't speak Arabic so
I don't really know but it could have
been and I know that you know Hollywood
in the 30s particularly uh was kind of
notorious for making a fake like making
it fake languages or not because they're
like you know what are they gonna do
like hire somebody on there that's like
a you know they gotta get the [ __ ] shot
now they gotta get the shots yeah so
they're not gonna like bring in a
dialogue coach and like have like train
all the actors so like me and a lot of
them were probably white people I have
to say I think yeah was the Nubian a
white yeah yeah
I'm pretty sure that that dude was like
a white guy yeah it was a white guy it
was a white guy it looked like a wife
well they wanted somebody who was like a
big bodybuilder and that's evidently who
they had although he you know a Nubian
kind of like any Ethiopian and not
Ethiopians have pretty caucusoid looking
features you know and they're
dark-skinned but you know they kind of
have a lot of I'm pretty sure I was away
I'm pretty sure as well I mean I have to
look it up but I'm pretty sure that's
what I do but yeah so I mean if you like
Dracula you probably like this well the
story is it's different but it's similar
you know what I mean like he has like
similar powers
to Dracula like he can kind of kill
people from a distance and he seems to
be able to kind of like hypnotize people
mind control like mind control and stuff
like that and yeah so he can do like
similar [ __ ] to Dracula you better shoot
he had television that's right because
he had this [ __ ] pool he is this HD
yeah this pool and then [ __ ] all the
dry ice to go down in there it was in
the middle of his room he had a [ __ ]
laid out pad too he brought the product
yeah ran over look at his patches this
is like ancient Egypt yeah let me show
you something that you've forgotten and
[ __ ] he started showing her that in
that pool and it was good effects yeah
swirling [ __ ] dry ice smoke and then
boom and he started he shows her the
past it was pretty cool it's like
television
Quantum television yeah show you the
past Boris I've had an ancient Egypt TV
yeah yeah in his living room yeah
yeah it was pretty cool but uh but but
yeah so like I said it's very similar
and started Dracula but not as overtly
horror like with maybe like a more
sympathetic villain I guess even though
you know like I said he's not entirely a
villain because he did get [ __ ] up
everybody does do bad [ __ ] but I mean I
really really liked uh I really liked
that Karloff got a role like this
because even though I mean he's greatest
Frankenstein's monster obviously but he
didn't really have any lines or anything
so this is actually like a real
character that he can like kind of chew
on and like you said he just [ __ ]
kills it in this movie he's [ __ ]
crushes it the makeup is amazing I love
love love the mommy makeup I love the
mummy makeup and I love the artist Bay
look as well I think that also looks
really yeah when he becomes Bay you know
sometimes he'll look at some dude and
they'll zoom in on his face and his eyes
will start glowing and it's good yeah
it's cool looking you can slightly see
the kind of damn papery looking skin
that he's got yeah I mean it's still I
think but they it it looked it was
really cool yeah I mean that's an iconic
image yeah really like where he's just
like looking all creepy like that
because he's just had such a great
[ __ ] and face like particularly great
face for horror if you're a fan of
[ __ ] the old Dracula you need to see
this this is karloff's response to
Dracula and I think he matched it I
think he matched it I think he did as
well yeah I think he did there's a lot
more character there
um you know he's got a lot more lines
he's in it a lot more
than Dracula's you know then Karloff is
in Dracula a lot of a lot of the drag of
the movies was just all the other guys
trying to catch him right they have that
in here but this one focuses more on
[ __ ] Imhotep himself yeah like his
place he's in it a lot you know so it's
a good movie yeah because because he's
in a different guys they don't actually
realize that he's The Mummy at first
like they just think he's this guy who's
helping them out like finding this tomb
and everything like that so they just
think he's a regular I'd watch it again
yeah I would as well I'd actually I'd be
curious to see the other ones I kind of
feel like you know the Brendan Fraser um
mummy movies that they made in the 90s
that we talked about
um those aren't really remakes of this
but the story is kind of similar like
the Tom Cruise one just that doesn't
have anything to do with this one really
I think it did maybe that had the
reincarnation I don't even remember that
like movie all that well but I think
like the Brendan Fraser ones were closer
but like I said don't go into this like
thinking that it's gonna be like a
horror horror movie it has horror
elements like people get killed and like
there's some creepy [ __ ] in it but it's
mostly like like a romance Thriller type
of thing I'd say Thriller with a
romantic right tragic romance yeah it's
kind of like that like more than overtly
horror I think right you're kind of
sympathetic to [ __ ] Imhotep yeah
uh because he did a you know he
what he did was wrong he shouldn't have
messed with that reincarnation spell or
that Resurrection spell back three
thousand years ago that was his
girlfriend he he loved her he was trying
to bring her back cops busted him yeah
he got busted then they [ __ ] killed
him killed him and they killed him they
mummified him alive which is [ __ ] up
come on and he accidentally gets revived
by his magic
comes back and tries to save the girl so
in a way he's a tragic hero yeah
um even though the girl doesn't the girl
his wife is Incarnate in this woman this
young Modern Woman yeah yeah she knows
who she was kind of she kind of
remembers who she used to be but in this
transferal ritual he has to kill her
yeah all right and he's like I was spent
thousands of years in the grave for you
and you can't take just a few minutes of
pain and he was gonna [ __ ] stab her
he was going to guilt him yeah
put her into a new body what it was a
new body or the old body I think he
wanted to put her into the old the old
body which it was mummified he had it
yeah he's gonna put her into the old
body and she'd come out and be like him
yeah which I guess they I guess he might
have been immortal
I mean I guess like for all intents he
was a wizard and I guess because this
The Scroll of Thoth like woke him up and
his body had come from a mummified
corpse so I guess he's just like he
could live forever hang out forever now
like a Dracula or like a like a vampire
yeah like a Dracula like a Dracula
I don't think he was alive per se he was
magically alive so now that he was
trying to do that to her I believe yeah
that's kind of what that's that's the
that's what I got that's why that's why
he had to kill her to like to kill her
to pop her soul out in the original body
and they would be immortal in those
[ __ ] yeah they'd be like together
because I think he even used the term
like living mummy did he not I can't
remember I think he said exactly that
they have to be like a little you have
to be like I am you know what I mean
you're right so it is a retelling of
Dracula
basically they're Immortals right yeah
but like I said the the whole
reincarnation angle that came up from
Dracula like that actually didn't come
out until like I don't think until the
seventh they copied it from this so
maybe they did maybe they did you're
right because this one like I said
wasn't really based on it was kind of an
amalgamation of a lot of different
things like I said there was I think
there was a Sir Arthur Conan Doyle story
yeah that was kind of like the Ring of
Thoth or something like that they kind
of used a little bit of that and they
kind of used the whole mummy's curse
thing although they don't really do a
lot with the curse do they because like
at the beginning they talk about like
the curve that has the scroll of thought
in it and it's like a big deal but the
curse doesn't really play that much into
the events that happen later on I mean
unless you can count like artist Bay
like squeezing people's hearts and kill
them the more we talk about it the more
I think about it the more I respect the
story yeah yeah I'd like to see it again
yeah yeah I can see it again it's a it's
a good story it's a good flick yeah
that's what I mean I really like it the
more I'm remembering and talking about
it the more I'm thinking about it
they're like yeah yeah it was good that
was a good one it was a good one yeah it
is a it's it's basically a retelling of
Dracula but it is but it it's different
enough to make it
unique yeah like its own thing it's its
own thing yeah it's it's good and Boris
Karloff is always yeah
I love him and everything yeah but yeah
so if you haven't seen it um it's on 2B
for free at the moment uh you know it's
at least in the United States I don't
know if you can watch TV in other
countries but um actually they have a
[ __ ] ton of old Universal monster movies
on there they got the original Creature
from the Black Lagoon 2 which is another
one that I want to talk about one of
these days because I really like that
movie too but yeah so go watch it if you
haven't seen it uh and that will do it
for this latest movie retrospective
we'll see you guys again on the next one
bye
foreign